ont montré que la population de la
France n'avait absolument pas augmenté à
cause notamment de la chute de la
natalité et d'autre part à cause de des
épidémies de choléra qui ont plus à
plusieurs reprises ont stopé net ce qui
restait d'accroissement et dans ces
conditions l'idée de faire de l'Algérie
une province française par son
peuplement en tout cas par la majorité
de son peuplement est apparu très vite
aux esprits lucides comme une illusion
et cela a été exprimé très clairement
dès le début des années 1860 par Ismaïl
urbain qui dans plusieurs brochures qui
ont retenu toute l'attention de Napoléon
II a expliqué que l'Algérie ne pouvait
pas être une colonie de peuplement mais
que la seule politique réaliste et digne
de la France c'était une politique menée
au profit de la population musulmane
largement majoritaire et c'est cette
idée qui a été reprise par l'empereur
Napoléon II sous le nom de politique du
royaume arabe mais malheureusement cette
politique n'a pas été comprise n'a pas
été admise par l'ensemble des
oppositions y compris voir surtout les
républicains et donc les républicains
qui sont arrivés au pouvoir en
1870 se sont dépêchés de
retourner à la politique de 1848
c'est-à-dire
l'Algérie divisé en département et
considéré comme un nécessaire
prolongement de la France alors je je je
conclus très rapidement sur tout le
temps qui nous reste jusqu'en
1954 on peut dire pour simplifier que
cette cette option des républicains n'a
jamais été sérieusement remise en cause
même s'il a eu quand même quelques
tentatives de
réforme visant à changer un peu le cours
de la politique française en Algérie
notamment en 1919 à l'issue de la
Première Guerre mondiale les les
réformes décidées par clleub Mano euh
mais aussi et surtout alors un fait
beaucoup moins connu les réformes qui
ont été décidées par le Comité français
de libération nationale présidé par le
général de Gaulle à Alger en
1944 alors on a retenu quelquefois le
l'ordonnance du 7 mars
1944 qui visait à donner des droits
politiques dans la cité française aux
membres des élites musulmanes quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes
euh justifiant de certains diplômes
certains
titres mais on a oublié que cette
réforme ne visait pas seulement les
élites qu'elle ne concernait pas
seulement les droits politiques mais
qu'il y a eu aussi en 44 l'élaboration
d'un d'un plan euh d'un plan de réforme
non seulement politique mais aussi
économique et sociale qui avait pour but
d'élever le plus rapidement possible le
niveau de vie de la masse de la
population
algérienne pour qu'il devienneent égal à
celui de la population française
d'Algérie et à celui de la population
française de France et là nous arrivons
bien au terme de la période que nous
devons envisager maintenant très bien
merci merci de cet éclairage qui montre
que comment la conquête de la Algérie
c'est faite de façon un peu empirique au
début maintenant qu'on a campé le décor
je vais donner la parole à Olivier le
court grand maison pour traiter de cette
question
l'assation comme vous le
savez de l'assimilation qui comme vous
le savez
continue aujourd'hui même en France et
il va traiter de ce thème avec un grand
point d'interrogation l'assimilation
était-elle un mythe républicain ou
pas ça a l'air
de merci madame la sénatrice mesdames
messieurs je ne sais si le choix de la
salle dans lequelle se déroule ce
coloque est le fruit du hasard ou d'une
volonté soucieuse des symboles mais au
fond qu'importe relativement au sujet
qui nous réunit aujourd'hui le nom de
clémenau nous rappelle opportunément que
des voix fortes se sont très tôt élevé
contre la politique de en quête et de
guerre colonial défendu par nombre de
républicains au rang desquels Jules
Ferry on le sait a joué un rôle majeur
je voudrais en guise d'introduction
puisque cela n'est pas sans rapport avec
le sujet de mon intervention
l'assimilation à mythe républicain je
voudrais donc citer quelques passages du
discours de clémau prononcé à la tribune
de la Chambre des députés le 30 juillet
1885 à l'occasion d'un débat extrêmement
important don le motif initial et le
sort à réservé à
Madagascar et après s'être opposé aux
thèses de Jul Ferry sur les devoirs
prétendus des races supérieures envers
les races inférieures clémenceo déclare
ceci je ne comprends pas que nous
n'ayons pas été unanime à nous lever
d'un bon pour protester violemment
contre vos paroles non il n'y a pas de
droit des nations dit supérieur contre
les nations inférieures n'essayons pas
de revêtir la violence du nom hypocrite
de civilisation la conquête que vous
préconisez c'est l'abus pur et simple de
la force ce n'est pas le droit CEN est
la négation forte parole assurément qui
contrairement à des discours convenus
souvent entendus de nos jours prouve que
certains contemporains et non des
moindres ont protesté au nom des valeurs
mêmes de la République contre la course
à l'Empire et ses conséquences
désastreuses pour les colonisations
conquises population don les les membres
et ce jusqu'en 1945 notamment en Algérie
mais pas exclusivement ne furent jamais
traités comme des égos mais comme des
sujets français selon les catégories
juridiques employé à l'époque pour les
désigner sujet français s'opposant ici à
la condition de citoyen puisque les
indigènes comme on les désigne avec
mépris pour signifier leur infériorité
et leur statut d'assujetti sont dans
leur écrasante majorité privé des droits
et libertés démocratiques élémentaires
l'assujétissement contre l'assimilation
nous y sommes et c'est bien le premier
qui a triomphé à cette privation des
droits démocratiques élémentaires
s'ajoute en effet des disposition
répressive exorbitante du droit commun
réunit dans un code le code de
l'indigéna dont la première élaboration
et application a eu lieu en Algérie en
février
1875 nommé code matraque par ses
détracteurs tenu pour un monstre
juridique l'expression est employé par
l'un des plus grands spécialistes du
droit colonial à l'époque Arthur girud
et plusieurs autres juristes de renom
cela même qui tout en défendant ce code
et quelques autres dispositions
d'exception comme la responsabilité
collective l'internement administratif
savent que ces mesures violent des
principes démocratiques élémentaires
sous des formes variées mais proches en
fait ce code fut étendu à l'ensemble des
territoire conquis au fur et à mesure de
l'expansion impériale de la 3e
république en droit comme en pratique
les mesures contenues dans ces textes
qui sont complétées par des pouvoirs
extrêmement étendus des gouverneurs
généraux témoigne de l'abandon de la
politique d'assimilation depuis
longtemps combattu par les plus hautes
autorités de la République le prouve
entre autres une déclaration très claire
du ministre des Colonies Georges
Clémentel en 1905 qui affirmait je cite
notre politique coloniale a
définitivement brisé avec ses erreurs
l'assimilation qui nous ont été si
funeste la mentalité française ne peut
pas plus s'acclimater au tropique que ne
le peuvent notre faune et notre flore et
au moment où ce ministre prononce ses
paroles et use de cette métaphore pour
récuser l'application des principes
démocratiques et républicains dans les
possessions françaises la thèse selon
laquelle l'assimilation est une
orientation coloniale dangereuse et
erronée et en fait erronée parce que
dangereuse pour la stabilité de l'ordre
colonial imposé par la France cette
thèse don donc est depuis longtemps déjà
au cœur des orientations impériales de
la 3e république et en cette matière
Clémentel ne fait en fait que prendre
acte des orientations nouvelles
appliquées par les autorités françaises
là encore Jules Ferry a joué un rôle
majeur puisque c'est lui qui avec
d'autres a combattu avec vigueur
l'assimilation au motif comme il le
soutient dans un texte consacré à la
Tunisie passée sous domination française
je cite que le régime
représentatif la séparation des pouvoirs
et ajoute-t-il et la précision est
évidemment fondamentale et aura des
conséquences extrêmement importantes
d'un point de vue politique et juridique
il ajoute ceci la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et les constitutions sont des
formules vies de sens dans les colonies
en raison c'est l'implicite de son
discours de la présence de population
indigène arriérée d'autres lieux
d'autres races surtout exigent donc
l'instauration d'un autre type de régime
politique puisque celui qui que celui
qui est établi en métropole ainsi fut
fait car au-delà du cas tunisien un
enseignement général est valable pour
l'ensemble de l'empire peut-être
effectivementé tiré plus grandes sont
les différences qui séparent les
Français et les indigènes plus il est
nécessaire d'élaborer des systèmes
politico-juridiques ad hoc distinct de
ceux dont jouissent les citoyens
français à l'unité de la législation
doivent succéder la diversité des modes
d'organisation coloniale et sur le plan
juridique le principe dit de SP spalité
que les juristes de l'époque ceux de la
3e république définissent ainsi je cite
là encore les lois métropolitaines ne
s'étendent pas de plein droit aux
colonies qui sont régies par une
législation propre comme l'écrit en 1931
pierre Darest un excellent connaisseur
du droit colonial auquel il a consacré
d'ailleurs un traité qui a longtemps été
une référence majeure c'est clair précis
et concis sous les esppices de la
République deux ordres politiques et
juridiques radicalement différents
peuvent désormais s'épanouir puisque la
règle est les lois et les règlements de
la métropole ne s'appliquent pas dans
les possession française sauf cas
exceptionnel et cela permet d'atteindre
je crois au fondement du droit colonial
et de la politique mise en œuvre qui ne
sont pas ce droit et cette politique
dérogatoire au principes républicains et
à la législation nationale de façon
marginale ou superficielle mais par
essence et c'est ainsi qu'en lieu et
place des principes universalistes
triompent relativisme politique
juridique et moral qui a longtemps
permis de justifier le statut imposé aux
indigènes de cela et pour cause les
contemporains étaient parfaitement
conscients de même ceux qui après 1945
ont é cherché chercher à établir le
bilan de la politique conduite par la 3e
république et comme l'écrivait un
professeur de droit Pierre François
gonidek en
1959 cette politique s'est caractérisée
par je le cite encore plus exactement je
commence par le citer pardon et la
citation est celle-ci beaucoup
d'assujettissement très peu d'autonomie
et un soupçon d'assimilation on aait
mieux dire relativement à la pondération
de ces différentes orientations d'où il
ressort qu'avant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale l'assimilation fut d'abord et
avant tout un mythe politique destiné à
faire croire en la compatibilité de la
colonisation et des principes
républicains et à établir la soi-disante
originalité de l'Empire français comparé
à ceux des autres puissances européennes
cette prétendue exception française qui
faisait écrire à un ancien ministre des
Colonies Albert sarot je cite que
l'honneur de la France était d'avoir
compris la première la valeur d'humanité
des races attardées et l'obligation de
les
respecter enfin et pour
conclure cette fois-ci enfin toujours
d'ailleurs en partie en tant
qu'universitaire mais également en tant
que citoyen je voudrais en ce lieu au
Sénat donc qui pour la première fois
depuis le début de la 5e République a
connu le changement que nous savons
rappeler cette incongruité pour ne pas
dire ce scandale l'existence de la loi
du 23 février 2005 toujours en vigueur
qui sanctionne une interprétation
officielle et apologétique de la
colonisation française Scand le regard
des principes démocratiques en effet car
si la puissance publique peut et doit
dans certains cas et en certaines
circonstances faire beaucoup de choses
en aucun cas elle ne saurait légiférer
pour consacrer quelque interprétation du
passé que ce soit sur ce point il faut
d'ailleurs rappeler que la France est la
seule ancienne puissance coloniale et le
seul État démocratique où pareille loi
existe j'ai la faiblesse de croire que
cela ne doit plus être ce qui signifie
pour le dire en des termes plus précis
que les sénateurs et les députés
nouvellement élus son'honoreraient en
l'abogeant madame la sénatrice mesdames
messieurs je vous
[Applaudissements]
remercie merci Olivier le court grand
maison pour ce rappel
historique très bien documenté de
première main euh on va rester sur cette
question du statut justement des de ce
qu'on de ce qu'on appelait les indigènes
ou les sujets français musulmans non
naturalisés ou Français musulmans de
souche nord-africaine en passant la
parole à sylvé tau qui va traiter du
régime pénal de l'indigène algérien
just alors effectivement je voudrais
revenir sur cette question du régime
pénal de l'indigénat non pas pour
l'aborder par les textes le droit mais
pour l'aborder dans sa pratique
effective il se trouve que c'est une
question sur laquelle j'ai travaillé
comme historienne non pas à partir des
textes des juristes mais à partir de
leur naissance dans les conditions
concrètes de la conquête en Algérie
d'une légalisation qui en fait est
fragile et incomplète ce qui ne signifie
pas que ces mesures n'existent pas et
qu'elles ne sont pas très largement
pratiquées et qu'elles ne sont pas
discriminatoires bien évidemment pour
être clair le régime pénal de l'
indigéna se composait de quatre mesures
il y avait le séquestre des biens qui
pouvait être collectif les amendes
collectives l'internement administratif
et ce qu'on appelait les pouvoirs
disciplinaires on sait relativement peu
de choses sur l'étendue de leur
application sauf de façon ponctuelle
parce que aucun historien n'a pris le
temps et son courage à demain je dirais
pour essayer de voir l'étendue de leur
application très concrètement tous ces
mesures sont nées des pratiques des
militaires qui ont été les premiers les
administrateurs de l'Algérie avec les
bureaux arabes et qui ensuite toutes ces
mesures ont été transmises je dirais aux
autorités civiles lorsque dans la 2uxème
moitié du 19e siècle on a substitué une
administration civile à l'administration
militaire du pays pour prendre l'exemple
des pouvoirs disciplinaires qui sont la
partie la plus rationnellement organisée
je dirais d'un point de vue légal de ce
régime pénal de l'indigénat en quoi
est-ce que ça consistait ça consistait
en la possibilité d'infliger des jours
d'amend et de prison pour punir une
liste d'infractions spécial le premier
texte relative relatif à ses pouvoirs
disciplinaires est une circulaire du
général Bugeot en
1844 toutes les mesures que je vous ai
cité n'ont jamais été rassembler dans un
volume dans lequel on pourrait trouver
tous les textes qui s'y rapportent
l'internement administratif auquel j'ai
consacré un ouvrage euh n'a jamais fait
l'objet de textes bien réglementés au
point queon est arrivé à une
contradiction assez paradoxale qu'en
1909 un député réformateur qui se
situait dans dans l'idéal républicain
dont on a déjà parlé qui pouvait inciter
à la contestation de ces mesures
discriminatoires voulait supprimer
l'internement administratif on lui a
répondu on ne peut pas monsieur parce
que comme il n'y a pas de texte on ne
peut pas déposer un projet de loi qui
dirait nous allons supprimer le texte
qui supprimerait qui prévoit
l'internement administratif et les
juristes se sont empaillés pour savoir
si l'interement administratif éit légal
ou non tout ça pour dire quoi c'est que
je crois que pour moi comme historienne
ce qui est important c'est de voir la
réalité de l'application concrète et là
on sait assez peu de choses visiblement
sur les quatre pans que je vous ai cité
je répète amonde collective séquestre
des biens internement administratif et
pouvoirs disciplinaires donc les
pouvoirs disciplinaires ont été à la
fois les mieux légalisés et les plus
employés et d'ailleurs en général quand
on parle de code de l'indigénat en
réalité on parle de ces seuls pouvoirs
disciplinaires parce que comme il y a
une liste d'infraction spéciales ça fait
penser à un code alors ces pouvoirs
disciplinaires ils étaient exercés par
du temps des bureaux arabes par les
militaires gérant les bureaux arabes et
puis quand on a mis en place une
administration civile ils ont été
confiés à deux types d'agents de l'État
colonial
dans les communes qu'on appelait les
communes mixtes qui n'avaent pas de
maire et de conseil municipal mais qui
étit géré par un administrateur c'était
l'administrateur de la commune mixte qui
possédait les pouvoirs
disciplinaires il y a une loi en 1881
qui a légalisé leur pratique mais elle
était bien antérieure les
administrateurs de commune mixte
appliquaient la prononciation d'amende
et de euh jour de prison en dehors de
tout texte depuis le début des années
alors très concrètement et c'est les
seules données que l'on a jusqu'en 1914
on a une vingtaine de milliers de peines
qui sont prononcées par les
administrateurs de commune mixte
j'insiste sur un point important et
relativement méconnu c'est que à partir
de
1897 les peines d'amende et de prison
pouvaient être converties en journée de
travail et d'après des statistiques qui
ont été rassemblées à l'époque parce qu'
il y avait des rapports qui étaient
établis tous les ans sur l'usage des
pouvoirs disciplinaires par les
administrateurs de commune mixte entre
1890 et 1914 ce sont pratiquement 600000
journées de travail qui ont été infligé
à des Algériens par des administrateurs
usant de leur pouvoir disciplinaire
c'est vous dire l'ampleur de
l'application de ce type de peine faut
pas imaginer des travaux de force parce
que c'était des travaux à exécuter quand
je dis travaux de force et qu'on allait
pas
euh construire des voies de chemin de
fer ou des routes par exemple c'est
cétait des travaux qui étaient exécutés
sur les communes donc ça allait être
plutôt des travaux d'irrigation des
travaux de débroussaillage et cetera
hein du du travail à l'échelle de la
commune donc des pouvoirs très amplement
pratiqués et qui pèsent comme une sorte
d'épée d'amoclesès sur la tête des
sujets algériens administrés par ces
administrateurs de communes mixte il y
avait par ailleurs des communes qu'on
appelait de plein exercice qui était
elle dotée d'un maire et d'un conseil
municipal dans les communes de plein
exercice c'était les juges de paix qui
exerçaient les pouvoirs disciplinaires
depuis un décret de
1874 et euh on ne sait strictement rien
de l'usage c'estd qu'on a pas de
statistique là sur leur application
concernant l'atterternement
administratif sur lequel j'ai travaillé
on avait plusieurs centaines de de
mesures par an avant 1914 et cet
internement administratif a pu prendre
trois formes soit l'interné était
assigné à résidence c'est-à-dire déplacé
d'une commune vers une autre soit il
était envoyé dans un pénitentier
agricole réservé aux internés du
Gouverneur général soit jusqu'en 1903 il
pouvait être envoyé dans un dépôt qui
existait à Calvi et qu'on appelait le
dépôt des internés arabe qui ferme en
1903 et qui est en fait un héritage
d'une pratique de la guerre de conquête
au cours de laquelle on a envoyé des
captifs algériens dans le sud de la
France en divers lieux notamment l'île
saintemarguerite qui a été le grand lieu
de l' internement des Algériens entre à
peu près 1840 et
1884 ce régime pénal de
l'indigéna il tente à s'éteindre après
la Première Guerre mondiale pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord il y a la loi
de
1919 après donc la première guerre
mondiale dans une logique de récompense
pour les Algériens et leur participation
à l'effort de guerre français on a
exonéré une grande partie de la
population algérienne des euh du régime
pénal de l'indigénna ou en tout cas
d'une grande partie ça représente à peu
près 400000 personnes tous des hommes
hein c'était des mesures qui en fait
bénéficiait à des électeurs donc à ce
moment-là des hommes euh et très
concrètement ça entrav l'application du
régime pénal de l'indigénat ce que
disaient les administrateurs c'est que
dès lors que dans leurs administrés
qu'ils souhaitaient punir il y avait une
partie d'entre eux qui étaient exonérés
euh par exemple des pouvoirs
disciplinaires ou des amendes
collectives bien il ne pouvaiit plus les
infliger parce qu'il se trouvaient pris
concrètement dans une flagrante
contradiction le résultat est qu'il y a
une tombée en désuétude dans la pratique
de ces mesur après la Première Guerre
mondiale très concrètement les pouvoirs
disciplinaires des administrateurs de
commune mixte disparaissent en
1927 globalement l'ensemble des mesures
n'est cependant aboli en 1944 avec
l'ordonnance qui a été cité par Guy
pervillier du l'ordonnance du CFLN le 7
mars
1944 que dire à partir de ce régime
pénal de l'indigénat il y a trois traits
de conclusions que je voudrais souligner
j'en auraai terminé premièrement je
voudrais insister sur le fait que quand
on parle d'assimilation il faut bien
préciser de quoi l'on parle parce qu'en
fait le terme a plusieurs acceptions
Charles Robert haeron qui a été un très
grand historien de de l'Algérie à la
période coloniale explique que le terme
en fait avait deux conceptions il y
avait une conception métropolitaine qui
est celle que que nous avons toujours en
tête et qui consiste à penser que
l'assimilation c'était pour tout le
monde et ça pouvait finalement
constituer si ça avait été réalisé ça
aurait pu constituer une sorte d'idéal
républicain où on aurait mené tout le
monde à l'égalité des droits ça c'est
une conception métropolitaine mais ce
que dit Charles Robert haeron dans un
ouvrage d'ailleurs ancien c'est qu'il y
avait aussi une conception coloniale de
l'assimilation qui était celle qui avait
cours en Algérie dans la population
européenne et qui consistait à pens que
l'assimilation elle ne concernait pas
les sujets coloniaux elle elle
concernait le territoire de l'Algérie et
ses habitants français je vous donne un
seul exemple qui est celui de la
création des départements en 1848 on
fonce bille en tête sur cette mesure en
expliquant que c'est le début de
l'assimilation en réalité il faut
regarder une carte pour voir ce
qu'étaent ces départements ces
départements au tout début en 1848 il ne
concerne que les poches de peuplement
européens pourquoi parce qu'on a en tête
que les premiers migrants européens ils
commencent à être nombreux ne peuvent
pas vivre sous administration militaire
alors que l'Algérie est majoritairement
sous administration militaire et donc
l'assimilation par l'instauration de
département en 1848 c'est uniquement
dans une logique coloniale de
l'assimilation c'est-à-dire dans la
logique qui consiste à faire échapper
les migrants européens au régime
militaire et à les soumettre eux à un
régime administra qui est assimilé à
celui de la métropole mais qui n'est pas
du tout pensé pour les indigènes entre
guillemets et le régime pénal de
l'indigénat il n'est précisément dans ce
contexte parce que quand on met en place
les premiers tribunaux qui fonctionnent
comme en métropole on met en place des
juges de paix on met en place des cours
d'assise tout ça ce n'est que dans le
territoire civil où vit la majorité de
la population européenne alors il y a
aussi des indigènes entre guillemets qui
vivent là mais la majorité vivent en
territoire militaire deuxème très de
conclusion sur lequel je voudrais aussi
insister parce que je crois qu'on a
baigné depuis ce matin dans une illusion
qu'il dont il faudrait se débarrasser
l'assimilation quelle qu'elle soit de
toute façon c'est une violence on ne
peut pas il faut se sortir de la tête
l'idée que s'il y avait eu assimilation
finalement l'Algérie française ou
l'Algérie coloniale aurait peut-être
constitué une société coloniale vivable
pour les sujets coloniaux elle est une
violence pourquoi parce que si elle est
incomplète elle est une discrimination
par exemple assimilation à complète il y
a des tribunaux qui fonctionnent comme
en France mais les indigènes ont les
punis aussi par le régime pénal de
l'indigénat assimilation à complète à
leur dépendant discrimination mais si
elle est complète elle vaut des
personnalisation et ça c'est un point
que l'on n'a pas encore abordé mais il
faut dire je crois
que elle cette assimilation a été
finalement une illusion coloniale mais
la vraie question qu'il faut faut se
poser c'est est-ce que les Algériens ont
voulait alors un
exemple notamment qui est celui de
l'école bien évidemment si l'extrême
faiblesse et la quasi absence de
scolarisation des jeunes algérien vient
d'une politique coloniale il y avait
aussi des réticences notamment dans les
élites algériennes avant 1914 à l'idée
d'envoyer ses enfants à l'école
française parce que l'éducation scolaire
fr fr était synonyme d'une
dépersonnalisation donc ayez bien en
tête que l'assimilation n'est pas un
idéal généreux qui aurait peut-être pu
permettre à l'Algérie française de
survivre mais qu'elle est de toute façon
l'expression d'une violence soit parce
qu'elle est discrimination quand elle
est incomplète soit parce qu'elle est
dépersonnalisation lorsqu'elle est
appliquée jusqu'au bout pour finir sur
mon propos et ce sera mon dernier mot
sur ce fait que les Algériens n'en
voulaient pas on en a pas mal de signes
mais qui qui sont relativement ignorés
en France parce qu'on baigne dans ce
ricit hein de cette assimilation comme
une forme d'occasion manquée qu'est-ce
qui nous montre qu'elle qu'il n'en
voulait pas je prends un exemple dès
1887 il y a des parlementaires français
qui s'inquiètent du statut
discriminatoire des Algériens ça a déjà
été souligné avec bon par exemple vous
avez le discours de Clémenceau hein tout
ça fait beaucoup débat hein dans les
institutions française il y a des
parlementaires français qui déposent un
projet de loi visant à faire des
Algériens des sujets de plein droit et
bien répond immédiatement une pétition
de notable de Constantine on est en 1887
qui est signée par plus de 1000 d'entre
eux et qui disent qu'ils ne veulent pas
de ce projet et qu'ils ne veulent pas de
la citoyenneté française pour finir sur
l'ordonnance de 1944 qui se place aussi
dans cette illusion de l'assimilation
comme une solution finalement pour que
l'Algérie française
perdure cette ordonnance
prévoyait donc que toute une série
d'Algériens suivant un certain nombre de
titres ou de diplômes accèdent à une
pleine citoyenneté française et on
estimait que cela aurait pu bénéficier à
65000 algériens très bien mais
concrètement seulement la moitié de ceux
qui avaient droit sont ensuite allés
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales du
premier collège et les slogans
nationalistes après 1945 scandit bien
que celui qui vote est un apostat et que
donc il tourne le dos au sien et à sa
société donc voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire en insistant vraiment sur
cette nécessité d'en finir avec cette
idée de l'assimilation comme une
éventuelle solution à la colonisation
moi je crois personnellement qu'elle
n'apportait strictement aucune solution
à l'occupation d'une société et la
domination d'une société par une
[Applaudissements]
autre merci Sy
on le voit bien le confinement des
Algériens dans un statut juridique
différent et donc forcément inégal et
inférieur conduira de proche en proche
de protestation révolte jusqu'à la
guerre d'indépendance et donc à
1962 période que Tod Shepard a très bien
étudié
et dont il nous va il va nous entretenir
et je m'empresse de lui passer la parole
merci bien merci
merci pour l'invitation et merci pour
l'introduction et merci au public d'y
être présent donc dans un article qui
apparu dans le dans les lieux de mémoire
sur direction de
pianora Weber historien d'origine
autrichien américain publi article sur
l'exagone sur l'idée de l'exagone et en
fait ce qu'il explique dans cetteette
article c'est que l'idée de l'agone
comme une description comme une méaphore
de la France paraî vraiment dans les au
début des années 60 en fait quand y
donne des dates précises c'est plutôt
vers
1962 Eugene Weber ne fait aucune lien
avec l'indépendance
algérienne mais je crois qu'on peut le
faire et
l'article suggère deux autres il y a
deux ironies un peu le premier bien
évidemment le première c'est que comme
l'historien français jardiel a étit le
premier de noter euh les liux mémoire ne
comportait aucun article dans sa
première version avec sur la
colonisation française sur l'Empire
français
d'utrem 2uxè ironie peut-être pas c'est
que Eugen Weber est très connu comme
l'auteur de de la fin des terroir et la
fin des terroirs à quelques pages à ça
jusqu'au dans ses derniers chapitrees
sur l'importance de
l'assimilation l'importance des exemples
coloniaux notamment algéri en pour les
efforts de franciser les terroir de la
France pour éliminer les spécificités
des campagne du sud-ouest du Nord et
cetera donc déécarter les langues
provinciales des langues des dialectes
des Patrois déécarter des spécificités
de forcer des gens d'être français et
pendant des années pendant les années 90
et au début des années 2000 cette c'est
coures quelques paragraphes dans le dans
le livre de de Weber était la grande
référence pour les historiens qui essay
qui insista qu'il fallait vraiment
prendre en compte à quel point l'Empire
français et surtout l'Algérie d
française a été formateur a été
fondamental pour ce ce qui est devenu
l'indépend l'histoire de France
l'histoire républicaine de
France malheureusement dans des façons
un peu ironique je dirais a l'attention
nouvelle qui a été portée sur l'histoire
algérienne de la France et l'histoire
périe de la France cont appar la France
depuis la Révolution française depuis
les dernières deux décennies depuis 20
ans a eu souvent une tendance
d'obscurcir le rôle les rôles
fondamentaux que l'Empire et en
particulier l'Algérie ont joué dans ce
ce qui est la France d'aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui est la France contemporaine et je
crois qu'il y a deux choses qui fait
qu'on a tendance à un peu mettre de côté
à quel point les institutions françaises
les façons que les Français vivent
aujourd'hui ont été façonnés par
l'Empire et par l'Algérie en particulier
le premier c'est une fixation qui est
absolument fondamentale et importante
c'estàd la fixation sur la violence les
conditions d'exception à quel point ce
ce qui était fait par la France en
Algérie dans l'empire était hypocrite
non républicain ultraviolente abnormal
ce ce qui est
vrai mais ce ce qui ça a permis de faire
aussi c'est d'ignorer à quel point la
normalité le la vie quotidienne des de
la gouvernance de l'Empire la façon que
la France a fait tous les jours et la
France la façon que la France a légiféré
pour maintenir ses empires ont eu des
impacts très importants sur la
gouvernance de la France et les Français
d'aujourd'hui donc c'està dire on fait
moins attention à combien c'était
semblable des deux côtés de la
Méditerranée parce qu'on est tellement
fixé sur je dirais avec raison parce
qu'il faut absolument mettre ça en avant
à quel point c'était une violence
extrême à quel point c'était une
situation abnormale et ça renforce une
deuxième tendance que je dirais est
plutôt rassurant c'est-à-dire une fix
une idée que l'histoire coloniale et
notamment l'histoire algérienne de la
France était une déviation dans
l'histoire républicaine que c'était pas
quelque chose qui tenit aux valeurs
républicaines que c'était quelque chose
qui aurait dû donc prendre fin c'était
nécessaire c'est dit inévitable que
l'empire prend fin que l'Algérie
devienne
indépendante mais en fait ce n'était pas
inévitable c'était quelque chose qui est
arrivé c'est arrivé en grande partie
dans le cas de l'Algérie par la force
des afforts des hommes et des femmes qui
ont sont sont mis en lutte pour gagner
l'indépendance mais quand on regarde
cette vision de déviation de quelque
chose qui devrait prend fin on écarte
aussi une autre compréhension de
l'histoire française c'est une surtout
l'histoire républicaine qui était à quel
point cette histoire était fondée dans
l'empire toutes les républiques après
tout av avaient des empires chacun
chacune de ces de ces ces cinq
républiques la plupart des républicains
étaient soit pour l'Empire ou n'ont rien
dit contre on a noté aussi souvent ce
qui était le plus critique de la
pratique impériale était des
interrépublicains ou des gens qui
faisait aucune référence aux valeurs de
la République donc il faut prendre ça en
compte et il faut voir à quel point
c'était quelque chose qui a fasconné le
gouvernance de la République et on peut
le voir vraiment je crois dans une façon
assez claire dans l'après 2è guerre
mondiale après 1945 après 1944 et on va
voir à quel point des hommes politiques
français et des fonctionnaires français
vont faire un effort pour réconcilier
pour garder pour inventer quelque chose
de nouvel des formes de d'institutions
nouvelles souvent innovatrices qui vont
essayer de garder ces territoires face
au courant de l'histoire face aux
exigences anticoloniales qui sont
tellement importantes à cette époque qui
sont tellement
pressantes mais aussi pour en fait on va
on voir ça très clairement dans les
débats sur ces projets d'essayer de
garder quelque chose qui va prendre en
compte les valeurs républicaine mais
faire autre chose avec faire quelque
chose de nouvel institutionnellement et
on peut le voir très clairement par
exemple dans la Constitution de 1946 la
Constitution de 1946 comme toute une
série de lois fondamentales de cette
période vont prendre des concepts
fondateurs de la République l'histoire
française et essayer de les réfaçonner
prendre le mot la République la
République est redéfin dans la
Constitution de 1946 de la République
française la République française
comprenne les départements métropolitain
et les territoires nouvellement dit
d'utremer c'estàd les anciennes colonies
les nouveaux les nouvelles colonies et
les anciennes colonies et les les
territoires d'utrer les anciennes
colonies avec de la nouvelle empire et
les départements d'ultrer réunion
Guadeloupe Martinique tout ça ça fait
partie de la République donc presque
toute l'Afrique
française et les citoyens on va
redéfinir les citoyens français tous les
habitants des territoire d'R des
colonies des départements d'R et de la
métropole sont maintenant nommés
citoyens français on fabrique aussi une
statue de citoyens d'union française qui
comprennent pas seulement la République
mais les protectorat le Maroc Chine la
Tunisie on donne aucune définition de
quelle loi ou quel devoir sont associés
avec ce statut de
citoyens français ou des citoyens de
l'Union française mais on affirme que ça
existe l'incohérence les incohences
multiples de ces nouvelles affirmations
de ces nouvelles définition de qu'est-ce
que c'est la République française les
citoyens français sont le plus évident
en Algérie pour les juristes ça reste in
certain il y a des débats jusqu'à 1954
est-ce que l'Algérie les départements
algériens font partie de la métropole
c'est ce qui est affirmé par le texte ou
est-ce que c'est autre chose donc est-ce
que l'Algérie c'est la métropole ou pas
on sait pas c'est pas clair
juridiquement pour ces départements
algériens et à 3 il deviendrait 12 et
puis 15 pendant la guerre d'Algérie 15
département algérien à la fin de la
guerde d'Algérie pour ces départements
il y a à l'opposé des départements
d'utremire ou des départements
métropolitains il y a une assemblée
algérienne comme les territoires
d'utremer donc une cohérence totale sur
la question de la citoyenité CE ce qui
devient clair avec le statut de
l'Algérie en 47 c'est que théoriquement
au moins
juridiquement les citoyens français qui
sont algériens et de statut coréque ont
les mêmes doigs que les autres citoyens
français métropolitain s'ils sont au
nord de la Méditerranée alors qu'ils ont
moindre ils sont dans le deème col s'
sont au sud donc toute une série
d'incohérences mais qui va être donc
plus clairement vu en Algérie et que en
fait face à l'insurrection face à la
Révolution algérienne la France va
encore une fois faire des efforts de
faire quelque chose avec une réflexion
assez claire dans les institution
françaises chez les fonctionnaires sur
le fait que la prétention assimilatrice
a été une illusion ça a été quelque
chose qui en fait avec la promesse
universelle a repoussé le plus des
algérien de la France et de la
République donc il fallait faire autre
chose il fallait garder la promesse
universelle mais il fallait prendre en
compte des mesures spécifiques pour
essayer de faire ramener les Algériens
vers la France donc en 1958 il y a à la
fois des déclarations de l'assimilation
complète du territoire de l'Algérie dans
la République française donc
l'élimination de toutes les lois
spécifiques et l'affirmation du fait
qu'il fallait garder une spécificité
algérienne avec le mat dans la
République du stat coréanique du stat
CIV statut civil coréanique mais avec
les plein dois politiques donc en 1958
avec la 5e République il y a 10 % des
parlementaires qui sont élus 10 % de
tous les parlementaires français qui
sont soi-disant musulmans il y a
l'affirmation qu'il sont des citoyens de
plein doit mais toute une série de lois
exceptionnelles donc on connaît le plus
important de ces lois exceptionnelles
les lois répressifes qui prétendaient
éliminer le nationalisme par la force
mais aussi une série de lois
exceptionnell qui donc exceptionnelle à
cette promesse d'assimilation complète
des territoire qui proposait de donner
plus de possibilités au soit-disant
musulmans pour qu'il deviennent des
pleines citoyens pour que on renverse la
tendance qui était fabriquée dans le nom
de l'assimilation qui a répoussé la
plupart des Algériens de la République
de l'égalité promise par le avec l'autre
citoyen
donc ce ce qu'on voit ici c'est toute
une série de possibilités imaginées par
les républicains à ce moment pour
essayer de redresser les
incohérences mais des
incohérences des efforts qui aussi
révèlent à quel point la République la
4e mais surtout la 5e République a été
fondée sur un effort de garder l'Algérie
française de faire rentrer les algéri de
la République et ce ce qu'on voit à la
fin de cette guerre cette fausse
promesse de on peut garder l'Algérie si
on change tout c'est pas l'élimination
de toutes ces différences ces
institutions restent en place et ils
sont en fait renforcé avec la sortie de
l'Algérie de la République française en
1962 mais on a tendance à oublier ça à
effacer cette histoire algérien de la
France et une façon qu'on a oublié ça
c'est encore une fois une fixation sur
un débat qui est que sur les valeurs de
la République et cette idée qu'il y a
que les valeurs qui sont en jeu ça aussi
ça ça c'est carérisé par la fin la
guerre où enfin les républicains ou une
défense républicaine se lève pour
défendre la République et ce n'est pas
contre la torture ce n'est pas contre
les violences massives qui subissent les
Algériens c'est contre le terrorisme de
l'os qui est vu comme donc la menace
grave qui va pas seulement gingriniser
la République mais qui menace de faire
capoter la République donc dans une
défense républicaine la gauche et la
droite gouliste va se retrouver pour
cibler le vrai ennemi de la République
donc pas les Algériens mais ces
Algériens ces Européens qui refusent la
fin de la l'Algérie française et c'est
dans cette défense républicaine et
défense des valeurs que la gauche va se
mettre avec de Gaul et que le
gouvernement de GO va aussi pouvoir
imposer toute une série de
réformes pour sortir la France de
l'Algérie mais des réformes comme par
exemple la mise en place de l'élection
du président une redéfinition de la
statue de de ce qui était vu comme les
propositions de la 5e République dans
une façon qui était vu comme
exceptionnelle pendant la guerre mais
qui devient
définitif en
62 donc pour dire que si on regarde de
proche des choses qui nous semblent avec
raison d'être incohérente de n'avoir
aucune sens de nos jours et sortu
d'avoir eu très peu d'effet sur la vie
des Algériens eux-mêmes on peut quand
même voir que ces efforts
institutionnels cet effort de garder
l'Algérie française à long temps de duré
a été en parti une défense tellement
violente de cette Algérie française en
parti parce que l'Algérie française le
gouvernance de l'Algérie française et
l'Empire en général a été très important
pour faire venir pour faire ce qui est
la République française aujourd'hui ses
lois ses institution et la façon que les
Français eux-mêmes sont gouvernés par la
République
[Applaudissements]
actuelle merci de Shepard pour toutous
ces éclairages roboratifs qui vont
nourrir le débat qu'on va ouvrir tout à
l'heure et auparavant pour conclure je
vais donner la parole
à à Christel taro qui a beaucoup
travaillé notamment sur la prostitution
coloniale dans cette Algérie coloniale
où les mariages mixtes étaient très
rares et où les les les les les les
rapports dans la prostitution étent le
seul rapport c'est presque les seuls
rapports sexuels de traiter donc de la
question du genre et surtout du statut
de la de la femme dans l'Algérie
coloniale
oui merci évidemment de de cette
invitation je suis extrêmement heureuse
de pouvoir participer à cette journée
d'étude sur l'amitié franco-algérienne
évidemment et de participer très
modestement avec avec les quelques
réflexions que que je vais faire
maintenant alors en fait ma ma
communication est un petit peu décalée
dans le temps puisqu'on m'avait plutôt
demandé de parler de du rôle des femmes
pendant la guerre d'Algérie donc je vais
essayer de très rapidement de de de
tenir les les les deux bornes
chronologiques si je puis dire je
voudrais commencer dans ce lieu très
symbolique par une citation d'une d'une
grande femme politique française Olympe
de gouge qui en 1791 rappelait que si
les femmes ont le droit de monter à
l'échafaud elles doivent avoir le droit
de monter à la tribune et je suis bien
aise de pouvoir ici m'exprimer en leur
nom collectif je suis
aussi je suis extrêmement ému aussi de
de parler de l'engagement des femmes
algériennes dans la guerre car je je
trouve que les femmes en général et les
femmes algériennes en particulier sont
toujours le parent pauvre d'une
historiographie qui est pourtant
extrêmement prolixe alors je voudrais
commencer mon intervention en parlant du
double confinement voire du triple
confinement auquel sont confronté
précisément les femmes algériennes
pendant la la colonisation française ce
triple confinement évidemment qui est
lié au fait d'abord qu'elles sont femmes
dans un monde doublement dominé par les
hommes par les hommes de leur propre
société bien sûr et bien évidemment par
la colonisation qui est une très
importante entreprise virile je ne peux
pas développer cette question bien sûr
mais peut-être qu'elle donnera lieu à
des échanges entre nous ensuite donc des
femmes qui sont d'abord dominées en tant
que femme qui sont dominées aussi en
tant que femme pauvre puisque
l'essentiel des femmes algériennes
pendant la colonisation française sont
des femmes issues des classes populaires
et particulièrement des classes
populaire de la paysannerie he
l'essentiel de la population algérienne
vit dans les campagnes
où les femmes évidemment ont un statut
très difficile et puis par ailleurs
elles sont soumises évidemment comme les
hommes de leur société au statut de
l'indigénna hein qui a été évidemment
très bien évoqué par mes collègues alors
ce qui est très intéressant c'est que
dès le début de l'Algérie coloniale la
question des femmes est centrale et elle
est centrale à de très nombreux euh pour
de très nombreuses choses puisque vous
imaginez bien qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
de colonisation sans femmes par
définition les femmes sont absolument
essentielles à la colonisation puisque
sans femmes les hommes ne restent pas
hein ce qui enracine les hommes dans la
terre c'est évidemment le fait qu'ils
construisent des familles se
reproduisent et cetera or les femmes
françaises et européennes sont peu
nombreuses dans le début de l'Algérie
coloniale ce qui pose évidemment
immédiatement le problème du partage des
femmes de ce que j'ai beaucoup oup
travailler le partage des femmes est ce
que vous évoquiez la question de la
mixité sexuelle comment est-ce qu'on va
gérer le fait pour un certain nombre
d'hommes français et d'hommes européens
d'avoir accès aux femmes algériennes et
donc il y a des débats très intéressants
très important pour savoir quelle
modalité doit doivent prendre évidemment
ces relations doit-on passer par le
mariage légal ce qui pose évidemment
beaucoup de
problèmes notamment
juridique d'autant que que comme vous le
savez les femmes françaises par exemple
sont soumises au code civil depuis 1804
et qu'ell donc elles suivent le statut
de leur mari ce qui voudrait dire qu'une
Française qui épouse un Algérien suit le
statut évidemment d'indigène de son
épouse qui dans un contexte colonial
pose un certain nombre de problèmes hein
donc la mixité sexuelle la question du
mariage la question de la prostitution
mais plus encore la question des femmes
devient un enjeu civilisationnel et
c'est là qu'on rejoint en fait êre la
thématique de
l'assimilation
puisque dans de très nombreux discours
de l'époque tout au long de la période
on comprend bien que à travers les
femmes on pense pouvoir assimiler la
population algérienne he et à de très
nombreux moments et dans de très
nombreux textes on comprend bien que les
femmes algériennes sont supposé pensé
théorisés comme plus assimilable et plus
assimilés que les hommes et que bien
évidemment à travers elle et à travers
les enfants on pourrait accéder
précisément à cette utopie de
l'assimilation
dont nous parlerit Sylvie Thau tout à
l'heure la question des femmes
algériennes a donc été centrale dans la
politique coloniale et malheureusement
on le sait peu on ne le sait pas assez
parce que ça n'a pas été assez étudié
évidemment cette question n'a pas été
jusqu'à une date récente pris à bras le
corps par la communauté historienne
qu'elle soit d'ailleurs française ou
qu'elle soit évidemment algérienne
elle est centrale jusque dans la guerre
d'Algérie pensez par exemple à la
bataille du voile en 1958 dont
probablement certains et certaines
d'entre vous ont entendu parler hein ce
rassemblement très médiatique en 1958 en
pleine guerre d'Algérie hein
où une association créée par les femmes
des généraux Salan et Massu vont
organiser un dévoilement public des
femmes place du gouvernement à Alger
hein et utiliser ce dévoilement pour
montrer à quel point l'assimilation
française est une réussite évidemment
puisque les femmes algériennes se
dévoilent spontanément et et donc elles
sont tout à fait d'accord évidemment
avec les principes défendus par la
colonisation française réformée post
Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors je voudrais maintenant
parler plus particulièrement du du rôle
des femmes dans la guerre vous avez vu
tout à l'heure pour ceux qui étaient là
la petite présentation du film l'extrait
du film qui nous a été proposé montrer
zoradriff parmi évidemment de très
grands noms de la guerre d'Algérie au
féminin et c'est très étonnant de de
voir quand on travaille sur la guerre
d'Algérie à quel point finalement la
l'engagement des femmes algériennes dans
la guerre a été une surprise elle a été
d'abord une surprise je pense pour la
société siété algérienne
elle-même
qui pensait le rôle des femmes de
manière assez traditionnelle finalement
et elle a été évidemment une surprise
extraordinaire pour le pouvoir colonial
qui lui-même avait largement évidemment
entretenu cette image traditionnelle des
femmes algériennes pensé et théorisé
comme soumise silencieuse invisible sous
leur voile c'est d'ailleurs très très
mal connaître l'histoire des femmes y
compris en contexte colonial de penser
qu'elles sont ce que je viens de dire
euh quelques très rares textes par
exemple nous montre tout à fait le
contraire peut-être que vous connaissez
par exemple ce très beau texte de fatma
aitmsour Amrouche histoire de ma vie où
elle raconte en fait à quel point
elle-même et et sa mère ont ont été des
femmes rebelles dans l'Algérie coloniale
et très tôt puisqu'il s'agit d'une
histoire qui euh a lieu à la fin du 19e
et au début du du 20e siècle
euh donc c'est une surprise l'engagement
des femmes dans la guerre d'Algérie euh
et et pourtant cet engagement est très
précoce et je ne dirais pas qu'il est
massif évidemment parce que les chiffres
officiels fournis par le gouvernement
algérien sont très faibles en 74 euh
étent répertorié par le ministère des
Anciens
mjahidin à peu près 10000 combatt
pendant la guerre d'Algérie ce qui est
un chiffre assez faible mais on sait
évidemment que ces chiffres ne disent
pas grand-chose de de l'engagement
général des femmes he puisque évidemment
il faut être répertorié il faut faire
acte de répertoriation et donc la grande
majorité des femmes évidemment n'ont
jamais fait ce type de démarche donc on
peut imaginer évidemment que
l'engagement est est est beaucoup plus
important et ce qui m'intéresse
particulièrement et je crois ce qui a
été laissé trop souvent de côté dans
cette affaire c'est que bien évidemment
les femmes algériennes s'engagent dans
la guerre en tant
qu'algérienne d'abord en tant
qu'algérienne dans une lutte qui
consiste évidemment à libérer leur pays
de la colonisation française mais elle
s'engage aussi en tant que femme et
évidemment le thème de la double
libération doit être évidemment discuté
discuté et
travaillé par l'histoire et les
historiens c'estàd que la la la lutte
nationale n'obbert pas la possibilité de
la lutte pour l'émancipation et
l'égalité entre les sexes dans
l'Algérie en
guerre alors cette cette idée n'a pas
été tellement mise en avant
et et pourtant y compris dans le livre
qu'elle écrit en
19 911 et que vous connaissez peut-être
Jamila Amran qui a écrit le premier
livre sur les femmes algériennes dans la
guerre rappelle que même s'il s'agit
d'une question minoritaire certaines
mjahidat et certaines fidayat portaient
cette idéal d'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes et il est intéressant en
fait de relire l'histoire de la guerre
d'Algérie et l'histoire de la
colonisation avec cette idée de
l'égalité parce que ça permet aussi de
repenser l'histoire de l'Algérie
contemporaine et de voir comment est-ce
que on pourrait aussi faire évoluer la
question de l'égalité des femmes dans
l'Algérie d'aujourd'hui et pas
simplement du point de vue historique
même si nous sommes plutôt là pour ça
euh enfin je voudrais très rapidement
parler des violences genrées de la
guerre comme je le disais la
colonisation française a été une
entreprise virile incontestablement hein
Olivier le court grandmaon le rappelait
tout à l'heure quand il rappelait
l'importance de la di de la force dans
la colonisation Albert Saro disait en
1921 dans un livre très célèbre au
départ la la colonisation n'a pas été un
acte de civilisation ça a été un acte de
force un acte de pénétration un acte de
violence
euh donc la colonisation a été une
entreprise virile et la décolonisation
l'a été aussi évidemment et il est tout
à fait évident que à travers la guerre
de
libération et à travers ce que je viens
d'évoquer sur l'égalité entre les sexes
s'est joué aussi du côté des Algériens
une volonté réelle de retrouver leur
statut d'homme plein et et entier
évidemment et la guerre a a donné lieu
évidemment à un certain nombre de
violences qui
ont entamé d'un côté et de l'autre cette
question de la virilité au travers
évidemment euh d'un
des grands problèmes d' d'un des d'une
des grandes douleurs d'une des grandes
souffrances de la guerre d'Algérie qui
est évidemment la question du viol comme
comme arme de
guerre alors cette question du viol
évidemment on la connaît
particulièrement à travers l'affaire
Jamila
bpacha que vous connaissez probablement
qui est l'une des grandes affaires
évidemment peut-être la plus grande
affaire du viol pendant la guerre
d'Algérie mais maintenant un certain
nombre de travaux parlent de ces
questions mais quand on parle du viol
pendant la guerre d'Algérie on parle
souvent du viol des femmes mais par
exemple peut-être Tod pourra nous dire
quelque chose dessus il y a aussi la
question du viol des hommes hein parce
que on comprend pas pourquoi est-ce que
la question des violences sexuelles se
serait arrêté évidemment euh euh aux
hommes donc il y a dans la la la la
question de la la guerre d'Algérie toute
une série en fait de euh de problèmes
liés aux femmes et aux genrees qui
permettent d'en donner une nouvelle
lecture une lecture plus complexe euh
une lecture
euh qui permet de renseigner le passé
mais aussi évidemment de travailler pour
l'avenir donc je terminerai là-dessus
maintenant et et je reprendrai peut-être
un certain nombre de choses pendant le
[Applaudissements]
débat
merci Christelle
tarot il nous reste à peu près 45
minutes pour un
échange que
j'imagine bien bien pimenté et moi-même
je vais me permettre à faire un petit
constat sur lequel j'aimerais que vous
réagissiez soit chacun soit certains
d'entre vous mais pas tout de suite dans
le cours du du débat c'est que à vous
entendre tous les cinq on réalise à quel
point le fait
franco-algérien la question de
l'identité de la citoyenté du statut
juridique des musulmans come on les
appelait à l'époque coloniale en France
informe encore apparaît encore en creux
en
filigrane dans le débat actuel et
surtout dans l'année dans cette campagne
électorale qui a précédé dans le débat
sur l'islam les bons lie
les
maghrébains la citoyenneté l'identité de
la République et surtout ce ce thème ce
que nous avions ce late motive dans
toute cette campagne et tous ces débats
on a l'impression on nous présente
l'idée
que que la République a constamment
proposé comme sur un plateau ce modèle
républicain aux indigènes et au peuples
coloniaux et que ceux-ci ont toujours
plus ou moins rejeté et et refusé or à
vous entendre à vous entendre on a
l'impression que ce modèle républicain
n'a jamais été sincèrement et
concrètement proposé au au au peuple aux
peuples indigènes comment comment on les
appeler
et et on a l'impression que cette
histoire n'est pas encore finie cette
histoire de que la République
l'universalisme républicain a toujours
buté sur les frontière ethnique dès
qu'on sort d'une de la population
européenne et bien cet
universalisme se casse les dents sur la
réalité ethnique des peuples coloniaux
voilà maintenant le débat est ouvert et
alors comment on va procéder on va
prendre peut-être des séries de
questions et ensuite vous allez répondre
à
chacun si vous êtes interpellé
personnellement alors Monsieur Levallois
déjà
il un
microur bon je voudrais d'abord dire
j'ai trouvé tout à fait passionnant le
l'ensemble des échanges de Ch matin car
il y a en effet un fil conducteur
extraordinairement fort et vous avez
venez de le signaler à l'instant c'est
ce problème de
l'assimilation et je trouve ça a été
décliné vraiment dans tous ces domaines
enfin dans toutes ces variations mais il
y a un point qui manque et et je dirais
c'est celui si vous en fait il y a trois
éléments dans l'assimilation il y a ce
que vous avz appelé l'assimilation
territoriale c'est-à-dire l'Algérie
c'est un territoire français vous avez
dit ensuite il y a l'assimilation
l'assimilation personnelle mais là il
faut distinguer il y a l'assimilation
civique ou civile c'est-à-dire les
droits civies et vous avez
l'assimilation personnel c'est-à-dire le
statut personnel et à ce moment-là cela
permet je dirais de d'avoir une de
comprendre l'ensemble de vos
interventions et de voir qu'elle se
complète car en définitive j'ai été moi
très heureux d'entendre Sylvie th dire
d'une façon très forte que
l'assimilation républicaine qui souvent
a été présentée comme un idéal et
Monsieur le court grandmaon l'a bien dit
tout à l'heure si vous voulait
normalement on aurait pu imaginer que
les choses se seraient bien passées si
on avait vraiment appliqué ce type
d'assimilation républicaine mais non
comme très bien l' l'a dit Sylvie tenau
c'est pas possible parce que où on
prévoit la totalité de l'assimilation
territoire droit CIVI et statut
personnel orquest ce qui s'est passé il
y a une date je pense que vous me direz
ce que vous en pensez c'est le ce fameux
Sénatus consultte de 1865 du 14 juillet
qui a été prévu pour donner la
possibilité aux Algériens de devenir
citoyens français à condition qu'ils
renonce à leur statut personnel donc il
y avait trois choses on les a reconnu
comme sujet français c'est-à-dire
faisant partie de cet ensemble
territoriale car avant il n'avait aucun
statut juridique il n'existait pas donc
une avanée certaine si vous voulez ils
sont reconnu comme en somme pouvant
avoir à la limite un passeport français
ensuite on dit ils peuvent devenir
citoyens mais devenir citoyens ça
voulait dire qu'il pouvait voter et
voter aux élections communales aux
élections des conseils généraux et
éventuellement plus loin pour élire des
députés mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à
ce moment-là le des gens comme Ismaïl
urbain et j'ai été sensible au fait que
Guy pervilet les cité tout à l'heure qui
lui voyait les choses du côté des
Algériens bien que français hein enfin
c'é é àé qui avait épousé une Algérienne
on revient pas là-dessus il il y avait
deux solutions à ce moment-là urbain a
essayé d'obtenir que l'on décide qu'il y
aurait une sorte de naturalisation
collective c'est-à-dire que la totalité
des Algériens aurait été considérés
comme des citoyens de l'Algérie citoyens
français ça voulait dire qu'ils auraient
eu le droit de vote et à ce moment-là en
effet il y a eu une campagne il suffit
de lire la presse de l'époque qui a dit
mais c'est pas possible on ne peut pas
imaginer que des gens qui sont polygame
enfin vous voyez tout tout ce qu'on a pu
décliner tous ces indigènes finalement
deviennent citoyens français et et la
majorité en fait dans les institutions
politiques locales et toute l'histoire
de l'Algérie en somme jusqu'à 1946 et
après c'est joué là-dessus c'est-à-dire
que à part on ne peut pas en définitive
aller jusqu'au bout de l'assimilation
c'est-à-dire considérer qu'on est
citoyen et en garder un son statut
personnel en devenant citoyen et final
l'assimilation vu par les la plupart des
Français et des colons a été de toujours
demander l'assimilation territoriale
pour pouvoir dire on refuse le le statut
personnel s'ils ne veulent pas
abandonner leur statut personnel les
indigènes algériens ne peuvent pas
devenir citoyens français et c'est ce
qui a permis si vous voulez de maintenir
en permanence le deuxième collège ou le
fait même que il ne vote pas c'est
finalement au nom de cette assimilation
territoriale et politique si vous voulez
que l'on on a refusé en maintenant
reconnaissant le statut personnel on ne
peut pas être français en gardant son
statut personnel et tout le problème
était là et ça s'est joué si vous voulez
avec ce Sénatus consul du 15 juillet du
14 juillet 65 où on n pas rendu possible
l'intégration dans la citoyenneté tout
en gardant son statut personnel et
c'était valable à l'époque pour les
Juifs et pour les les Isra enfin les
Israélites et pour les musulmans voilà
ce que je voulais dire merci Monsieur Le
Valois je rappelle que vous avez écrit
deux ouvrages consacrés à Ismaïl urbain
madame ensuite Gilbert Meier et ensuite
Monsieur Tout auout làbas et le monsieur
tout au bout je vous je vous prie
d'essayer d'être le plus bref possible
le plus concis plutôt je voudrais
simplement rappeler que la conquête
d'Alger a été décidée sous la
Restauration par Charles X et que
c'était justement pour effacer l'échec
de cette restauration donc on voulait
une diversif une une une
diversification par exemple comme en
1824 il avait été décidé la conquête de
l'Espagne or donc tout de suite après
quelques jour enfin à la fin de juillet
des des journées de 1830 à ce moment-là
il y a le régime de Louis Philippe et à
ce moment mais quand même la conquête
continue c'est-à-dire la la conquête des
territoires puisque il y a MDEA il y a
Blida avant il y a aussi la conquête de
Constantine qui se fait en
1835 avec l'échec du général Closel qui
est repris après par le général Valy
donc c'est pas seulement 1840 c'était
déjà bien avant la conquête qui qui
continuait bon et ensuite je voudrais
tout simplement ajouter une remarque à à
la brillante intervention de Madame
tarot pour dire simplement que nous nous
avons assez nous algériennes que soit
toujours mis en exerc de ces fameuses
moujahidetes parce que en réalité ça
peut-être été une surprise pour pour le
colonisateur de voir l'engagement de la
femme algérienne mais la femme
algérienne c'était qui à l'époque
pendant la colonisation je parle surtout
des femmes dans les classes paysannes
dans ces classes pauvres qui étaient la
majorité et bien c'était tout simplement
la gardienne des valeurs de l'Islam
entendons-nous pas de l'islam auquel
voudrait nous confronter certains euh
certains intégristes maintenant mais la
valeur tout simplement de leur religion
comme dans les campagnes françaises les
paysans étaient attachés à la religion
catholique pour la plupart donc c'était
ces gardiennes le roui le roui comme
elle l'appelait n'était pas vraiment de
leur monde de leur religion c'était
l'étranger donc ces femmes ont véhiculé
ces ces valeurs et je peux dire que j'ai
vu moi originaire de de de d'Alger même
des tas de femmes des bonnes qui
portaient dans leur coupfin des armes
des des millions et qui passaient à la
barbe des parachutistes quand il y avait
la bataille d'Alger et pour elle ça ne
causait pas problème parce qu'elle
risquait d'être d'être arrêtée à tout
moment d'être torturée par la suite mais
elle le faisait parce que elle
considérait ça que c'était leur devoir
de défendre les enfants et dans les dans
les montagnes c'était les femmes qui
cuisaient les kessr qui cuisaient le
pain pour le donner donc il y avait un
lien d'appartenance avec les les
moujahidines alors s'il vous plaît c'est
toute c'est une grande partie des femmes
algériennes qui ont participé à merci
beaucoup merci bien
[Applaudissements]
oui bonjour moi j'ai quatre remarques à
faire j'essayie d'aller aussi vite que
possible d'abord sur la conquête de
l'Algérie euh tu t'en es tenu Guy ce ce
que tu as dit n'est pas faux à ce que
j'appellerai la factualité de l'immédiat
je rappellerai quand même que la
conquête de l'Algérie avec la thèse de
Pierre Guiral sur Marseille et l'Algérie
euh montre que il y a eu des origines
beaucoup plus anciennes dans l'histoire
de temps long ou dans l'histoire du
temps social en interférence avec les
explication que donne brodel sur la
coupure de la Méditerranée et dans le
dans un temps plus long encore lorsqu'on
lit par exemple en arable les lives
deahmed Madani il ne dit jamais Almar le
colonialisme il dit toujours
alarbi le colonialisme croisé donc ça je
pense que ce sont des choses qui sont
aussi à prendre en compte mais mme si
évidemment on peut pas tout dire dans un
colè deuxième remarque ça c'est pour
Olivier le court grandmaon je rappelle
que j'ai été un de ceux qui ont lancé le
comité de lutte contre la loi de février
2005 et que nous avons organisé à Lyon
il y a exactement 6 ans de cela un
colloque ça s'appelait pour une histoire
critique et citoyenne en finir avec les
pressions officielles et les lobbyes de
mémoire ça a été publié à la découverte
en 2008 et ça vient d'être publié à
Alger par les éditions InAs
il y a quelques mois en français et en
arabe troè remarque sur ce qu'a dit
Sylvie thénau je rappelle que pour
l'école il faut faire une différence
j'ai étudié cela entre l'avant et
l'après Guer 14 c'est vrai qu'avant la
guerre 14 ça c'est une thèse connue
l'école française a du mal à s'imposer
il faut dire qu'il y en a pas beaucoup
non plus mais que après la guerre 14
après le passage de 300000 hommes jeunes
Algériens de l'autre côté de la
Méditerranée c'est exactement l'inverse
qui se produit dans les années 20 on
refuse du monde les écoles refusent du
monde parce que il y a pas assez de
place pour les accueillir donc je crois
qu'il faut faire la différence entre les
périodes d'autre part sur les occasions
manquées bon je me suis empaillé assez
souvent avec le regretté Ageron pour
savoir ce qu'il en est moi je lui disais
il y a pas eu d'occasion manqué parce
qu'il y a pas eu d'occasion tenté bien
or en témoigne ce que dit Ahmed koulaxis
dans son sa thèse les socialistes et la
Afrique du Nord et que qui a été
corroboré par la très très longue
interview que j'ai faite de Fat Abbas en
avril
72 il a été
euh reçu par la Commission du suffrage
universel en 1931 et on lui a dit M
monsieur Abbas vous voulez quoi on veut
le droit de vote on veut élir des
députés ah mais c'est pas possible vous
avez le code personnel musulman ad c'est
pas possible du tout et ben alors vous
savez ce que vous faites vous faites
vous nous faites un décret ser mieux
vous l'abolissez ce code musulman
évidemment moi je vais raller je vais
protester mais finalement la violence
triomphe toujours réponse du bon juriste
français ah mais non votre code
personnel musulman on ne veut pas y
toucher nous sommes trop respectueux de
l'islam bon autrement dit on aait un
discours ce discours n'était pas assumé
et il était même nié euh dernière chose
que je remarque c'est
une adresse et simplement une
communication à Christelle tarot les
livres sur les femmes sont souvent pas
écrits en
français par exemple la la thèse superbe
c'est c'est un travail de terrain de
l'Algérienne enfin de l'algéro
canadienne rimgelli de l'université
d'Otawa va enfin être édité elle
s'appelle fight with with us women
willancipate c'est un travail
remarquable c'est ce qu'il a de mieux
sur la question à mon sens je signale
aussi mais là c'est pas encore prêt
d'être
merci il ne reste plus que 20 minutes et
on encore de tire parce que je tiens à
dire ces titrre le PhD de Natalia vin
surahid independent Algeria n'est pas du
tout connu non plus vient de paraître il
y a 3 jours enfin et là je vous promets
que je que je me tais le livre de fariel
Lalami sur les femmes algériennes contre
le code de la famille je vous promets
que j'en ai terminé merci infiniment
donc maintenant merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces précisions alors une dernière
question le la plus concise possible
s'il vous plaît pas de contreconférence
et parce que pour que le max non non
celle qui par ord par chronologie par
ordre chronologieque et après vous non
était avant vous le monsieur
ouais bonjour Bonjour Je vais me
présenter je suis abeloni journaliste je
ne vais pas poser de questions je vais
simplement dire merci euh merci pour
cette
vérité merci à l'ambassadeur d'avoir
choisi ces perles de l'histoire parce
que si je reprends
euh si je reprends la la parabole du
Christ des nos de Cana on a toujours
l'impression que le meilleur va venir
après et là on a déjà le meilleur et et
j'espère que ce qui viendra après va
être
superbe vraiment vous venez de rendre
justice
rendre justice à l'histoire et et
l'histoire grâce à vous retrouve ces
lettres de noblesse merci pour cette
vérité c'est tout ce que j'avais à dire
je n'ai pas de question j'ai envie
simplement de vous dire merci merci et
bien ainsi
soit-il
monsie
très bien bonne
réaction bonjour s zerouni je voudrais
avant de poser ma question de manière
très succinte remercier Monsieur pardon
Olivier le cour grand maison pour sa
brillante intervention qui rassure parce
que au-delà de la France officielle il y
a quand même des des intellectuels
français pardon qui gardent une certaine
lucid
par rapport à des événements très
tragiques ma question est très simple
euh lors du 2è mandat euh présidentiel
de Monsieur Jacques Chirac le président
Jacques Chirac à l'époque a présenté
officiellement ses
excuse pour la responsabilité de la
France dans la déportation des Juifs ça
a été un acte historique sans précédent
euh et je pose la question part tout
particulièrement à Monsieur le cours
grand maison est-ce que l'ALG pardon la
France officielle
d'aujourd'hui pourrait un jour euh
présenter ses excuses au peuple français
pardon au peuple algérien et non pas aux
officiels algériens au peuple algérien
soit sous forme de repentance soit sous
forme d'excuse soit sous forme de
reconnaissance peu importe est-ce que
vous pensez que ça serait possible un
jour merci on a pris note de votre
question une dernière intervention et
après je donne la parole au au
conférencier parce qu'il nous reste on
est quand même pressé par le temps 20
minutes ouiur très brièvement par
rapport à ce qui a été dit de très
stimulant sur le régime d'exception du
code de l'indigénat et les
développements qu'on a fait ensuite
Sylvie
tau il y a une couche nouvelle qui a été
apportée de 1901 à 1931 à cet édifice et
qui est plein de sens et plein de
conséquences parce que ça sert de modèle
au cours même de la guerre d'Algérie
comme Syvie ten l'a très bien étudié
dans ses ouvrages ça étéit la création
de tribunaux indigènes
d'exception tribunaux répressifs
d'exception euh qui on été instauré en
1901 qui en rajoute une couche parce
qu'il ne s'agit plus simplement de
donner au militair puis à
l'administration des pouvoirs de
répression judiciaire mais de
d'introduire en Algérie euh un mode
d'organisation des tribunaux vis-à-vis
des sujets indigènes qui qui notamment
supprimait le droit d'appel ce qui est
important c'est qu'à l'époque ça a donné
lieu au sein du camp républicain un
débat extrêmement vif il y a eu un débat
en 1903 à l'Assemblée où toute une
partie de républicains il ont vu quand
même une une atteinte insupportable au
droits de l'homme deuxème aspect je
termine là qui dit exception veut dire
théorie raciale alors ça peut être la la
rhtorique républicaine qui ne gênait
personne à l'époque sur les
les les races attardées qu'il fallait
amener à la civilisation en Algérie ça a
pris une forme plus théorique
euh psychiatrique il y a une école
psychiatrique d'Alger Antoine
porau qui a théorisé dans des articles
qui à l'époque étaient acceptés comme
allant de soi la propension criminelle
de l'indigène algérien c'était le le
titre d'un de ces articles célèbres
c'est important parce que ce genre
d'approche fait encore des petits
lorsqu'on nous explique aujourd'hui
qu'il y a un fanatisme iné de la
population
musulmane et d'origine algérienne
notamment c'est un ça découle
directement de ces théories je rappelle
aussi que Fran Fanon c'est dans la
critique il était lui-même psychiatre de
cette théorisation raciale qu'il a jeté
les bases de son propre cheminement vers
son engagement pour la libération
nationale donc maintenant euh pour nos
conférenciers comment procéder vu le la
diversité et la convergence des
questions qui commencerait peut-être
guiperv euh oui je vais essayer bon euh
oui enfin juste quelques remarques oui
ce que ce qui a été dit donc par Michel
Levallois très très pertinent et j'y
souscris entièrement alors simplement je
pense qu'on pourra préciser quand même
qu'il y a eu une vraie politique
d'assimilation qui a été appliqué à une
minorité de la population donc d'une
part aux immigrants européens non
français une loi de 1989 notamment qui a
donné la pleine citoyenneté française y
compris
donc la soumission à toutes les lois
françaises le Code civil par exemple et
donc
l'attribution des droits de civies
intégraux donc au aux enfants
d'immigrés espagnol italien maltais et
cetera né sur le sol algérien
c'est-à-dire sur le sol français et puis
il y a eu aussi la politique
d'assimilation appliqué aux Juifs à
partir de 1870 puisque les Juifs qui
faisaient partie des indigènes soumis au
au Code du Statut enfin au Sénatus
consulte du 14 Ju 1965 ont reçu avec le
décret Crémieux 1870 la citoyenneté
française pleine et entière donc il y a
eu une vraie politique d'assimilation
qui a été un plein succès mais seulement
au bénéfice d'une minorité euh et puis à
part cela oui je pour oui répondre à
Gilbert mniier et à la dame qui a parlé
avant effectivement j'ai été très très
expéditif pour essayer de résumer un
processus qui en fait étit très
compliqué on peut dire que d'une part
l'idée de prendre ALG a été proposé
avant juillet 1830 en
particulier depuis une vingtaine
d'années il y eu au moins deux
propositions de prendre algé enfin
faites par des Français plus quelques
autres proposé à la France par des
étrangers mais si on remonte encore plus
loin dans le temps il y a eu en fait une
succession de grandes phases tout à fait
contradictoire puisque au 16e siècle
François 1er a défini une politique a
défini une politique très originale
d'alliance avec les Turcs pour combattre
charlequin qui lui menait mené la
croisade contre les contre les Turcs et
contre les les Barbaresques euh au
contraire au 17e siècle la
France à la suite de la conversion
d'Henri
du protestantisme au catholicisme est
revenue à une politique de croisade euh
jusque jusqu'aux années 1680 et puis de
nouveau elle s'est rapprochée de
l'Empire ottoman euh les relations
étaient plutôt calmes au 18e siècle mais
à la fin comme je l'ai dit de nouveau
l'idée de prendre Alger est revenu mais
d'autre part comme je l'ai
dit le la prise d'Alger le 5 juillet
1830 par le gouvernement de Charles X
n'a pas entraîné une volonté immédiate
malgré cela de conquérir toute l'Algérie
et d'en faire une terre française et il
y a eu une improvisation avec
d'abord la la non décision d'évacuer qui
est devenue dans les faites une décision
de rester en 1833 34 ensuite une
politique de conquête limitée et enfin
en 1840 la conquête totale donc tout est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que j'ai
dit on l'a bien compris vous nous l'avez
bien expliqué merci guiper Villet alors
Olivier le cour Grand
maisan Pardon sur trois points très
rapidement sur la question de la de
l'assimilation je crois qu'il aurait
fallu éventuellement je le dirai là très
vite traiter aussi de la façon dont en
métropole
pendant l'entre de guerre et après 1945
il est traité de celui qui est appelé
immigrés nord-africains enfin bref et
qui notamment dans la thèse célèbre de
George Bocco grand spécialiste de
l'immigration notamment de ce qu'il
appelle
avec petite pointe assurément de
condescendance l'migrations exotique et
dans lesmigration exotiqu qui en fait
une émigration coloniale l'ouvrier
nord-africain notamment d'origine
algérienne et considéré pour des raisons
qui sont ethnico-raciales comme
inassimilables dans la métropole et
c'est cette thèse qui euh fonde aussi la
dangerosité de la présence des ouvriers
des travailleurs nord-africains en
métropole comparativement aux ouvriers
ou aux immigrés d'origine européenne qui
peuvent présenter dans certains cas un
certain nombre de dangers mais dont les
dangers ne sont pas à chercher dans leur
caractéristiques ethnic-raciales mais
bien plutôt dans des caractéristiques
politiques je pense en particulier oui
aux Italiens accusé entre autres par
moco mais par d'autres aussi de porter
le trouble parmi la classe ouvrière
française en raison de leur combat
antifasciste cette thèse du du de
l'inassimilabilité de de l'immigré
nord-africain rebondit après 1945 mais
la thèse se déplace pour des raisons qui
sont à la fois historiques et
académiques et en parti lier d'ailleurs
à la publication de l'ouvrage de Claude
lvistros RAC et histoire et qui tend à
discréditer radicalement sur le plan
scientifique et académique le concept de
race tandz si bien que relativement aux
immigrés nord-africains ce qui est mis
en avant ce n'est plus tellement leur
caractéristiqu ethnicraciale qui tente à
disparaître mais et de ce point de
vue-là ce qui s'est passé ces derniers
temps témoigne hélas de la permanence ce
genre de représentation ce qui est mis
en avant c'est l'islam en tant qu'elle
est un complexe à la fois cult cultuel
bien sûr et culturel qui rendrait
l'immigration nord-africaine absolument
inassimilable dans les 12 eau entre
guillemets de la République publque
reconquise sur la loi du 23 février 2005
je n'ai jamais eu le la prétention ni
d'avoir le monopole de sa critique et
d'ailleurs heureusement nous avons été
effectivement un certain nombre
d'universitaires d'historiens ou autres
à considérer lorsque cette loi a été
votée qu'elle était un scandale et
qu'elle ne devrait plus être et je pense
que étant donné les changements qui ont
eu lieu récemment il paraît qu'il y en a
eu il me semble que cela devrait
effectivement avoir quelques
conséquences sur ce point
euh la dernière chose sur la question de
la
reconnaissance là en tant que peu
importe le statut d'ailleurs euh
repentance non c'est un terme que je
n'emploie pas parce qu'il est d'abord il
est lesté d'une sorte de connotation
péjorative et religieuse qui n'est pas
la mienne il est en général utilisé par
celles et ceux
qui sont opposés justement à la
reconnaissance des crimes coloniaux
commis par les républiques entre autres
mais pas elle seul et donc là aussi il
là encore il me semble semble
effectivement qu'après la reconnaissance
par le Président de la République
Jacques Chirac et non pas François
miteran faut-il le rappeler de les des
crimes commis par Vichi après la loi
tobira reconnaissant pour la première
fois en France l'esclavage comme crime
contre l'humanité les nouvelles
autorités politiques de la France
sonorit effectivement à
reconnaître que et ça a sans doute à
voir avec ce qui va être traité en fin
d'après-midi sur l'avenir sonnerait
effectivement à reconnaître que la
France ses autorités ses militaires et
son pouvoir politique ont commis et
justifié et légitimé pendant très
longtemps des crimes de guerre et des
crimes contre l'humanité entre 1830 et
1962 merci
syv syv s'il vous plaît oui trois points
rapidement un premier point où je vais
être très historienne à la suite des
travaux signés et signalés par Gilbert
Meier moi je crois que pour ma part
l'ouvrage que je préfère sur la question
des femmes en Algérie c'est celui de
Neil McMaster burning the veil il a
notamment un chapitre extraordinaire sur
la violence des dévoilements de mai 1958
qui est vraiment un modèle et qui est un
livre totalement méconnu à part des
séminaires où on l'invite et où il y a
15 personnes pour venir l'écouter alors
que c'est un ouvrage majeur deuxème
chose sur les occasions euh tu dis alors
c'est une discussion que nous avons eu
de multiples fois donc pour le public je
livre ma réponse Gilbert parce que je te
l'ai déjà livré euh pour moi c'est pas
la question de savoir si elles ont été
elles ont été tentées ou pas c'est la
question de savoir des occasions de quoi
faire et pourquoi faire et c'est là que
je dis qu'il y a une illusion parce que
globalement on peut avoir deux
interprétations de ce qu' aurait pu
changer les dites occasions non tenté ou
manqué au cours de l'histoire on peut
être dans un dans une version de
l'histoire finalement très colonialiste
qui consisterait à dire ça aurait permis
à l'Algérie française de survivre et ça
aurait évité qu'on la perde en gros ce
qui est pas je pense le le point de vue
aujourd'hui qui peut être défendu
simplement il y a une autre version à
mon avis peut-être plus intéressante
c'est de dire que s'il y avait eu des
reconnaissance des droits politiques des
Algériens leurs aspirations auraient pu
s'exprimer d'une autre façon et
peut-être que tout cela étant de la la
supposition bien sûr leurs aspirations
auraient pu s'exprimer autrement et que
nous aurions peut-être éviter cette
violente guerre finale deuxè
point je crois qu'on on mélange enfin ou
alors c'est moi qui me suis trompé de
discussion on a beaucoup parlé
aujourd'hui et jusqu'à maintenant de la
politique métropolitaine en parlant de
l'assimilation c'est un thème
intéressant et il est évident que quand
on parle de cette politique on pose des
questions à la France d'aujourd'hui et
au régime républicain on lui pose la
question du racisme on lui pose la
question de la discrimination c'est
légitime c'est normal ça M beaucoup je
dois dire cela dit que quand on
regarde
historiquement la société française y
compris métropolitaine de toute façon le
régime républicain a passé son temps
àevenir à ses principes généraux et à
ses valeurs je ne rappelle pas les
femmes je rappelle pas les vagabonds je
rappelle pas les prostituées il y a des
rapprochement intéressant à faire à mon
avis entre les modalités de traitement
des populations stigmatisé et exclus de
métropole ou je pense aussi aux
étrangers et le traitement des sujets
coloniaux je veux pas dire que c'est la
même chose mais je crois que vraiment le
régime républicain on peut l'interroger
de toutes les façons et en tant que
citoyenne moi la la leçon que j'en tire
c'est qu'il faut toujours être vigilant
et ne pas croire que parce qu'on vit en
régime républicain avec des valeurs
affichées et des textes de droit qui
proclam un certain nom de principe et
bien tout va bien dans notre société
tout n'a pas été mal qu'au colonie c'est
ça que jeux veut dire et vigilance elle
est toujours de mise quand je disais que
je m'étais trompé peut-être de débat
c'est que je veux dire qu'à mon avis
aujourd'hui la vraie question à poser
c'est comprendre ce passé et que pour
comprendre ce passé il faut dépasser la
question de la politique métropolitaine
la politique des gouvernements
métropolitains elle ne nous permet pas
de comprendre ce qui s'est passé en
Algérie de 1830 à 1962 ce qu'il faut
c'est aller dans la société coloniale et
donc on peut passer des heures à parler
de la politique métropolitaine des
réformes tentées ou pas tentées de la
contradiction qu'il y a avec le régime
républicain mais nous sommes tout à fait
en dehors de la société coloniale et ce
qu'il faudrait pour comprendre ce qui
s'est passé c'est tenter de la pénétrer
un peu mieux et y compris de se poser la
question ce que j'essayé de faire très
rapidement tout à l'heure de savoir et
les Algériens ils l'ont vécu comment
cette colonisation et n'ont pas vécu
qu'une politique décidée à Paris avec
toutes ces contradictions c'est un
environnement social qu'il faut essayer
de restituer euh voilà j'en ai
[Applaudissements]
terminé merci Sylvie tenau je donne la
parole à Tod Shepard qui dans un de ces
articles je crois avait défini la
République française d'après
l'indépendance algérienne comme une
république
blanche
blanche européenne je crois que j'ai dit
ah mais européenne c'est donc ça vaut la
peine juste pour répondre à quelques
affirmations et quelques questions aussi
qu'en 1958 après tout il y avait une
collège unique en 1958 donc avec le 5
République il y avait la formation de
tous ces doigts donc c'était pas une
incapacité républicaine donc c'était
quelque chose qui a été fait et c'était
fait avec toute une série d'analyses qui
suggérait qu'en fait l'application de
l'assimilation avec une promesse
universelle de tout le monde pour faire
la même chose ils ont que à abandonner
ce ce qui fait leur spécificité était
leure toute une série d'analyses
d'experts et des gens qui étaient qui
ont fait rentrer dans le gouvernement
dans la fonction publique pour appliquer
cette nouvelle politique d'intégration
qui disait qu'en fait le racisme
Français envers les algérien éta un vrai
problème que le racisme français
pourrait être mesuré par ses effets et
pas simplement par des intentions aussi
bonne qu'elle soit c'està dire que la
République n'a jamais appliqué une
politique exéivement raciste à la jamais
mis soi-disant des catégories raciales
dans ces lois dans ces catégories mais
qu'elle a été raciste c'est ça qui
disait des gens qui gouvernent la France
une partie au moins dans l'application
de cette politique d'intégration donc il
y a toute une série de bonnes choses
d'un point de vue présentiste qui ont
été faites donc c'est pas qu'il y a
incapacité après 47 il y a toute une
série de possibilités toute une série
d'analyses qui disent à peu près ce ce
qui disent les historiens d'aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire queil y avait toute une
série de fausses routes toute une série
de prétentions égalitaires qui n'ont pas
été appliqué mais aussi toute une série
de d'efforts soi-disant égalitaires qui
ont des effets discriminatoires massifs
et qu'il fallait donc renverser ces
tendances et c'est cette histoire un peu
trouble c'està-dire qu'il y avait le
président de l'Assemblée nationale en 58
était un homme algérien pas chagaboualem
il y avait 10 % des sénateurs 10 % des
des députés qui étaient algériens il y
avait aussi un effort de faire venir
l'islam dans la République d'essayer
d'appliquer la laïcité donc c'est une
séparation entre l'islam l'Église a la
mosquée et l'État qui n'a jamais été
fait par les républi avant mais aussi un
effort de faire rentrer l'islam dans la
pleine mesure comme ils ont été juste en
train de faire avec l'Église catholique
à l'époque je vous rappelle 1959 c'est
la loi Debré qui fait rentrer l'Église
dans l'école l'école privée donc c'est
une période d'invention qui il faut
comprendre comment ça a été effacé une
façon qu'on est c'est dire qu'on est
face à quel point l'Algérie et les
Algériens ont joué un rôle pas seulement
dans les les guerres pour faire libérer
la France de la menace allemande ou
autre mais aussi dans la façon que les
républiques ont été construit et après
après 62 ont pas seulement on fait en
sorte la République fait en sorte
d'exclure les Algériens de la citoyenité
républicaine donc il ils enlèvent en
dépit des accords d'avion ils enlèvent
les citoyenité de plein doit de Naité de
naissance des Algériens et on efface
cette histoire algérienne africaine
mondiale de la France républicaine pour
faire en sorte que tout ce qui était
française vientne de la France tout ce
qui a été fait pour la République vien
de la France c'était pas les colons
c'est les pied noirs qui ont été mauvais
c'est pas les Français qui étaient
responsables donc c'est cet effacement
de l'histoire mondiale et l'histoire en
particulier algérienne de la France qui
je voulais mettre en avant en parl de la
façon qu'on fabrique une histoire
européenne et que européenne de la
France alorselle été faite par cette
histoire par beaucoup d'autres personnes
en dehors de
l' merci d'ailleurs c'est une idée que
vous développez aussi dans votre livre
1962 l'indépend qui transforma la France
alors pour conclure je pense qu'il faut
conclure maintenant monsieur le
Président n-ce pas les meilleur chos en
une fin mais justement justement vous
allez avoir le redoutable privilège
Sylvie tarot Christel tarot de conclure
d'accord la dernière mais pas la moindre
d'accord très bien alors juste trois
remarques il me semble effectivement que
l'une des tendances actuelles de
l'histoire et c'est une bonne chose
c'est de ne plus faire une histoire
cloisonnée c'est-à-dire de faire une
histoire de la France d'un côté une
histoire de l'Algérie de l'autre mais
d'essayer de faire une histoire de des
interactions des complexités entre
l'Algérie et la France et c'est pourquoi
cette histoire ne peut pas être écrite à
une seule voix elle est nécessairement
elle doit nécessairement être écrite à
deux voix c'est-à-dire qu'elle doit être
nécessairement écrite entre les
Algériens les Algériennes et les
Français et les Françaises qui sont dans
une histoire partagée pour le pire ou
pour le meilleur mais cette histoire est
partagée et on doit la faire ensemble
donc ça c'est le le premier point que je
voulais évoquer j'adhère tout à fait à
ce que disait Sylvie Thau pour
comprendre ce qui s'est passé en Algérie
de 1830 à
1962 il faut regarder l'histoire au rat
du sol par le bas et donc j'adhère tout
à fait aussi à ce que vous avez dit et
je crois l'avoir dit mais peut-être je
l'ai dit trop rapidement que la question
de la guerre de libération nationale a
été une question massive et les femmes
se sont massivement évidemment impliqué
à l'intérieur quelle que soit la manière
dont elles l'ont fait et quel que soit
ce qu'on pense de la manière dont elles
l'ont fait ce n'est pas vraiment le
problème en réalité et c'est aussi ce
que j'avais essayé de faire à travers la
prostitution coloniale c'est-à-dire de
regarder en quoi la colonisation avait
eu des impacts sur une des catégories de
la population algérienne qui était la
plus stigmatisé précisément du fait
qu'elle se retrouvait dans cette mixité
sexuelle si problématique et dans une
une mixité sexuelle doublement
problématique parce que la sexualité
mixte est un problème et parce qu'il
s'agit de mixité
prostitutionnelle deuxièmement enfin
c'est une banalité banalité de dire que
la République est discriminatoire la
République est évidemment blanche elle
est évidemment masculine elle est
évidemment riche et elle est évidemment
hétérosexuelle et tout ce qui n'est pas
dans ces quatre catégories est
discriminé et est discriminé depuis
l'origine et a commencé par les femmes
je rappelle quand même qu'en France les
femmes ont voté pour la première fois en
1945 c'est-à-dire l'un des pays les plus
tard enfin les premières élections c'est
bon peu importe en tout cas le droit de
vote a été posé en 44 et elles ont voté
postérieurement donc c'est une évidence
et par ailleurs je voulais rebondir sur
ce que disait Michel Levallois je trouve
ça très intéressant que vous ayez
utilisé comme catégorie permettant
d'exclure les algérien de la de la
citoyenneté par le senénatus consul de
65 que vous ayez utilisé la catégorie
polygamie
parce que ça renvoie précisément à ce
que j'ai essayé d'évoquer très
rapidement dans mon intervention alors
je je vais pas évidemment discuter ici
pour savoir si la polygamie était réelle
ou fantasmée elle était en partie réelle
et en partie fantasmée mais ce que je
trouve très fascinant et là le retour
par l'histoire métropolitaine est tout à
fait nécessaire c'est dans le même temps
qu'on dit aux Algériens qu'ils sont
inassimilables à la vie politique et
publique et donc à la citoyenneté parce
qu'il serait polygame nous avons en
France un système le Code civil qui
permet d'implanter une double morale où
presque tous les hommes français sont de
facto
[Musique]
polygame
les institutions républicaines ne sont
pas toujours aux couleurs de la société
benoî duquen et ses invités débattent de
la place faite à la diversité dans la
vie politique française aujourd'hui on a
le sentiment que plus on parle de
diversité et moins on regarde le talent
les compétences des gens et plus on
regarde la couleur en essayant d'en
faire plus plus et et moins on en fait
en réalité parce que moins on laisse la
possibilité aux gens qui ont vraiment le
talent les compétences nécessaires pour
avoir ce type d'ascension de s'exprimer
la diversité pour vous ça a été un atout
ça a été un handicap en
général dans votre parcours
professionnelp d'une certaine façon ça a
été un atout parce que parce que enfin
moi je prends mon cas je parle pas je
parle pas de façon collective mais dans
mon cas ça m'a facilité la vie par
rapport à mes aînés parce que je suis
arrivée à un moment en politique où il y
avait un tel déficit de
représentativité du personnel politique
que il y a eu un appel d'air on avait
besoin de renouvellement de jeunesse de
de diversité de féminité aussi donc ça
m'a aidé vous aviez toutes les
cases arriver voilà mais je voudrais pas
que notre réflexion s'arrête là parce
que après une fois que vous êtes dans la
place comme disent les rappeurs c'est là
que les difficultés commencent
c'està-dire qu'après on vous fait en
permanence aussi un procès en en
illégitimité on on on pense en
permanence que vous êtes là parce qu'il
a fallu remplir les cases en question et
donc il vous faut démontrer six fois
plus que les autres que vous êtes
compétente que vous avez quelques
convictions et et que vous avez du cœur
à l'ouvrage donc moi j'ai le sentiment
finalement ça fait 10 ans que je suis en
politique j'ai le sentiment d'avoir dû
démontrer et prouver beaucoup plus je
partage ce que vient de dire Najad parce
qu'au fond dès qu'on arrive en en
politique alors
déjà vous découvrez que vous êtes noir
en fait parce qu'on vous le rappelle
tout le temps euh c'est vrai parce
qu'avant vous vivez normalement et puis
moi mes problèmes je les attribue plus à
des questions sociales au fait que voilà
je vis d'une famille monoparentale avec
une mère qui avait plus de travail et et
tout d'un coup là case diversité c'est
extrêmement violent et euh associé en
plus j'arrive au gouvernement je suis
associé à Rachid adatifamara
systématiquement euh on ne cherche pas à
savoir la diversité justement des
parcours des unes et des autres on est
on est toujours mis dans le même sac et
vous avez en plus de ça un devoir de ça
c'est la charge supplémentaire dev voir
d'exemplarité c'est-à-dire de oui de
réussite vous êtes censé représenter des
gens vous représentez pas l'ensemble des
Français mais des gens et et et une
catégorie de la du pays en général
venant des cités donc moi j'ai beau dire
oui c'est vrai que je viens des citer
mais en plus Mo avant mon père était
ambass était diplomate et ma mère était
prof de lettre ça ça correspond pas à
l'histoire officielle qu'on voudrait
raconter donc il vaut mieux que je ne
parle pas de ça et que je raconte la
partie juste citée et comme ça ça
correspond à l'idée qu'on se fait de moi
vous même c'est ce que vous racontez
aussi quelque fois en disant moi B RAC
les deux je raconte les deux parce que
les deux sont la vérité est-ce qu'on a
régressé par rapport à cette époque où
il y avait monerville à la présidence du
Sénat oui parce que problème c'est il
est pas bon le constat parce qu'on sait
bien que quand l'Assemblée nationale et
le Sénat ne sont pas réellement
représentatifs de la réalité de la
société française il y a une distorsion
dans les textes législatives qui sont
adopté par rapport aux préoccupations de
cette société française je vous en donne
deux exemples rapides par exemple est-ce
qu'on aurait eu une loi sur sur
l'abolition de l'esclavage s'il y avait
pas eu Christiane tobira pour la
défendre à l'Assemblée nationale voilà
est-ce qu'on l'aurait eu s'il y avait
pas eu Christian tobira pour l' porter
je suis sûr que non est-ce qu'on aurait
eu une loi reconnaissant les effets
positifs de la colonisation qui serait
passé aussi facilement que cela à
l'Assemblée nationale si on avait eu
davantage de députés issu des
immigrations maghrébines par exemple je
suis sûr que non elle est là la
distorsion et aujourd'hui par exemple
au-udelà de la couleur de peau vous avez
pas suffisamment d'ouvriers à
l'Assemblée nationale et donc vous
n'avez
pas% pas une suffisante prise en
considération des problématiques
auxquelles sont confrontés les ouvriers
ou les classes populaires de manière
générale ou les gens des banlieux est-ce
que vous avez suffisamment de
représentants à l'Assemblée nationale
venant des banlieux ou des femmes c'est
la distorsion dans le lé plalité la
pluralité de la société française c'est
pas simplement l'issue de l'immigration
c'est est-ce qu'il y a le les classes
populaires est-ce qu'il y a des forumes
est-ce qu'il y a c'est ça la pluralité
de la société et pas simplement est-ce
que on a une affiche beton comment faire
les cota je ne crois pas que la France
soit pays à de quotas donc il faut
vraiment commencer par il faut il faut
faire un travail sur soi il faut que les
élites les gens qui ont des
responsabilités que les partis
politiques acceptent les femmes plutôt
que de payer pour pas les avoir qu'ils
acceptent d'ouvrir leurs PES c'est les
partis politiques les entreprises il
accep la pression je veux dire personne
n'a jamais c'est ce que disait n c'est
c'està dire s'il y avait pas eu des
députés d'autres Mar pour avancer la
question et s'il y avait pas commencé
par un mouvement social en 1998 disant
il y en a marre de la manière dont on
raconte la fin de l'esclavage
l'abolition de l'esclavage faut aussi
signaler que les esclaves il ont
contribué et que il faut quand même que
la France reconnaisse ça si tu n'avais
pas eu ce mouvement ça ne serait pas des
tout d'un coup il y a pas une flamme qui
serait descendu dans la T MV il est déjà
là je dis pas qu'il il est là R peu de
contrainte un peu peu d'autorité dans la
politique il faut changer des pratiques
et les pratiques elles sont changées on
le sait par exemple pour les femmes on
sait que les les pratiques par rapport
aux femmes n'ont pas été changé parce
que tout d'un coup simplement on s'est
dit bon on va être quand même plus
gentil avec elle parce que quand même
elles font tout ça ellesoccupe des
enfants non ça a été quand même il a
fallu aussi prendre des
choses CDD CDI intertérim quel sera le
contrat de travail de demain Élise Luca
et ses invités s'intéressent au rapport
des salariés avec avec le monde du
travail si on regarde la situation
aujourd'hui oui il y a une précarité il
y a une précarité
croissante même si la majorité des
contrats de travail en stock sont encore
très largement des contrats dur
indéterminés c'est vrai que l'accès à
l'emploi très souvent se fait
aujourd'hui au travers de CDD ça
s'accentue
puis per CDI est en danger quel est la
proportion de CDI signé par rapport au
premiers contrats qui sont signés en
stock en stock on est encore à 75 % à
peu près 80 % de CDI dans dans le
travail à peu près stock global des
contrats qui existent maintenant la
majorité des contrats 2/3 des contrats
plus de 2 tiers même des contrats pour
des jeunes qui arrivent sur le marché du
travail c'est je crois que c'est 80 %
ouis 2/ers ça dépend oui enfin c'est du
CDD ou du oui du du CDD voire pire que
le CDD parce que c'est ça aussi c'est ce
qu'on appelle les stages hein ou c'est
c'est pire que le CDD et ça bon ça c'est
significatif aussi d'une période de
crise
en France comme ailleurs écoutez je suis
assez largement d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit d'une manière générale
sinon que je ne le place pas dans la
même perspective par exemple sil est
tout à fait exact que vous avez la
plupart maintenant des contrats sont des
CDD au début une très large majorité se
transforme en CDI il faut le savoir
aussi auourdui et donc le problè l
majoritébi écoutez de ce que nous avons
nous sommes à plus de 70 % alors c'est
pas 99 mais parfois au bout de beaucoup
de CDD non oui c'est tout le problème et
c'est justement là-dessus que je
voudrais insister je pense pense que il
y a une il y a vraiment une perspective
que nous devons tous changer par rapport
à la vision du CDI qui ne mérite pas
cette excès d'honneur et du CDD qui ne
mérite pas cette indignité le gros
problème du CDD c'est qu'aujourd'hui
toute la société s'emmêle le banquier
qui ne prête pas d'argent le bailleur
qui ne va pas passer qui va pas
permettre de louer un appartement mais
je c'est précisément pour ça d'ailleurs
vous nous avons signé tout de même
pendant la période depuis 2008 nous
avons a une quarantaine d'accords avec
les organisations syndicales dont
beaucoup ont été signés par
l'organisation Jean-Claude Mali parce
que nous ne restons pas les bras ballant
par rapport à cette difficulté nous
venons de signer pas plus tard que au
1ier semestre 2011 quatre accords sur
l'emploi des jeunes parce que c'est le
second point que je voulais souligner en
réalité vous avez ceux qui sont à
l'intérieur du contrat en effet le le
stock comme comme dit Jean-Claude Mailli
qui sont disons mieux protégés que les
autres et puis vous avez ceux qui sont à
l'extérieur de debout c'est-à-dire les
jeunes et les vieux et les et les
seniors qu'est-ce qui est dangereux
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est la
flexibilité en soi qui est dangereuse ou
est-ce que est-ce que c'est ce qu'on a
fait la pression des financiers ou des
actionnaires sur les groupes alors je
pense qu'il faut aller lentement là
parce que ce sont deux
choses convergentes mais différentes euh
commençons par la flexibilité et je
trouve
inquiétant que des dirigeants en
particulier ceux du MF excusez-moi mais
aussi ceux de l'État considèrent qu'on
va régler le problème de l'emploi et de
la crise par la flexibilité du travail
je pense que c'est une un raisonnement
totalement intenable pourquoi parce que
s'il y a pas assez d'emplois pour toute
la population active il faut trouver
d'autres solutions on peut en trouver il
suffit de les inventer c'est sûrement
pas la réduction administrative du temps
de travail qui résoudra le problème mais
il y a d'autres solutions qui sont
peut-être le partage du travail le
partage de la richesse mais sur d'autres
bases